so how is
uh if you can do sort of a big sweeping
progress of javascript how has
javascript changed over the years any of
you from those early 10 days
with a quick addition of garbage
collection and fixes around security
how is this evolution that now it's
taken over the world
in this it's been a bumpy ride because
the standards body got shut down after
microsoft i think um took over the web
and then felt punished by the usv
microsoft
antitrust case can you speak to this
antibody like
that was a fun ride too because netscape
had uh taken the lead
with the web and html innovations like
um frames and frame sets tables and the
w3c was sort of off even then sort of in
sgml land heading toward xml
la la land i'm going to be a little
harsh on it this is html i'm sorry
html was the the precursor markup
language to html it was sort of the
more extensible standard generalized
markup language it was it was a xml like
pointy brackets but it had all sorts of
elaborate syntax for doing
uh different semantics and this is why i
think
uh you know tbl and others who wanted to
do the semantic web then took xml
forward but they had this uh or some of
them anyway had this strange idea they
could replace the web with xml or that
they would upgrade the web
to bxml and it couldn't be done worse is
better had
concrete meaning the web was very
forgiving of html
including sort of minor syntax errors
that could be
error corrected like error correction
isn't generally done in programming
languages because
that's another amazing thing about html
is like it's more like biology than
programming yeah exactly and so uh
xml was in its standard form super
strict and
could never have admitted you know the
kind of users who were committing these
errors
and the funniest part was microsoft said
hey we're doing xml but the way they put
it in internet explorer under the
default media type
put it through the html error corrector
oh wow
so they kind of bastardized it to make
it popular and usable and accessible
and so xml as a pure
you know thing was never going to take
over and the w3c was kind of
not fully functional because nescape
wasn't cooperating with them
we thought about where to take
javascript and we realized our standards
guru carl
cargill realized there was a european
standards body that had already given
microsoft fits by standardizing parts of
the windows
31 api which european governments insist
on they said microsoft we can't use your
operating system without
some standards and microsoft said you
know here's our docs and and the
government said no we need a european
standard so this body called the
european computer manufacturers
association
ecma which eventually became global and
became a proper noun instead of an
acronym
right it's uh it's just one capital e
now with a lowercase cma
right and as uh one of the early
microsoft guys i met when we first
convened
a working group to talk about javascript
said it sounds like a skin disease
but it gave uh i mean maybe you'll speak
to that but it gave the name to
javascript of ecmascript
that was the standard name because java
was a trademark of sons they were so
aggressive they were
sending cease and desist letters to
people whose middle european heritage
meant their
their surname was javonko and they
called their website jamanco.com
and son was sent them a letter saying
you're using java at the start of your
domain name you must cease and desist
i love marketing more than anything else
in this world uh
so so ecmascript and now is popularly
named as es
plus version i would say people use js
more than anything
people still say javascript javascript
books sorry i mean when you're referring
to it's usually javascript and when you
want to refer to a version of javascript
you'll say es6 es5
yes or now they've gone to years which
is kind of confusing because it's an
offset of
2009 es6 is yes
2016. uh yeah it doesn't match the years
perfectly
yeah yeah so so what uh what what were
the choices made and how did
javascript evolve here so we we took
this this this new standards body who
which had
we thought uh sort of a proven record of
standing up to microsoft but microsoft
sent a lot of people they sent some some
people who were
pretty good and then when they realized
that i was there and netscape was not
going to
you know just bend over and do whatever
they wanted they sent somebody really
good he was a smart guy he did a lot of
work on the first draft of the spec
uh sean katzenberger he's left microsoft
he
even did what i sort of did he told his
bosses i've
stopped bugging me to do other things
i'm focused on this because it took a
lot of focused work to create the first
draft of the spec
and i was still holding i was spending
almost all the plates i had like
part-time help in certain areas and on
the front-end integrations i had the
front-end guys
but i i couldn't take as much time as
sean was to write the draft spec but i
had to participate because
i was essentially helping write down
what the language did in areas where we
didn't like what it did and
microsoft didn't agree we sometimes got
away with slight changes
and that's the story of standards you
have different implementations
and depending on their market power they
interoperate where you have agreement
and where they don't
the dominant one usually sets this de
facto standard
and then you should probably reflect
that into the jury standard
and this happened with javascript uh
over the time this netscape went down
and microsoft went up
we did the first edition of the standard
codified in 1997
in france we had a trip to nice uh which
was very memorable
for any interesting reason or just
because it's nice and and ecmas european
and ibm and others were you know
there uh mike kalashaw an ibm fellow was
a britisher and we the
the the guy who ran actually at the time
john vandenbelt was quite a
uh a raconteur and a very fun guy and he
had us out for you know the great
you know frida mayer the boya bays and
was the standardization process
beautiful or painful that those early
days you as a designer
it was painful because it was rushed now
guy steel was contributed by sun
so even more than sean you had this
giant brain guy steel helping
bringing some of that scheme magic he
even brought richard gabriel for fun
richard wrote the fourth clause of the
standard
which is kind of an intro to what
javascript's all about so we had some
really good people and we didn't fight
too much there was some tension where i
was
fixing bugs and i was late to a meeting
and sean katzenberger microsoft was
actually
mad like where is he we need him and
when i got there
i saw that only he saw this sort of off
by one bug in somewhere in the spec and
i saw it too and i said there's a fence
post bug there and then we kind of
locked eyes and we realized we were on
the same page and we kind of he wasn't
mad anymore
what were the features that are being
like struggled over and debated and
thought about and
it was mainly writing down what worked
and what we thought should work in the
edge cases that didn't
interoperate or that seemed wrong uh but
we were already laying the groundwork
for the future editions that
i was already implementing i was still
trying to lead the standard
by using the dominant market power to
write the code that actually shipped
so the de facto standard would lead the
de jure standard and i was putting in
the the missing you know function forms
that i didn't have time for in the 10
days
so this is the engineering mindset
versus the theoretician so you didn't
want to create the perfect language but
one that was the popular and
shipped and all that kind of you could
say there was i was standing on the
shoulders of giants so there was a
staged process where i had to hold back
things that were well designed by others
in other languages and i could
imitate but i couldn't do them all in
the 10 days so they came in in
1996 in 97
and they came into the third edition of
the standard which was finally finalized
in 1999.
but at that point netscape had been sold
to aol and was
which was a decent exit considering and
uh
you know had previously been uh
mercilessly crushed that netscape was
selling the browser along with
server software that it acquired after
its ipo
and microsoft was just under pricing it
so there was no way
to compete with that microsoft was also
you know
making internet explorer the default
browser in windows
which is called tying and antitrust law
and they were doing even more brutal
things there's the famous
uh investor he did very well on google
so he's a billionaire rahm sri ram and
he was
sales guy or head of sales at netscape
and
he got off the phone looking
action-faced after compact called and
said
microsoft just told us they're going to
pull our windows license if we ship
netscape as the default browser
wow this is so there is some bullying
going on there was totally
material in the anti-trust case but but
javascript escaped into the standard
setting where there was fairly good
cooperation microsoft
had a really good guy on it and you know
guy steele was there for a time and and
there was some good work
but after the anti-trust case and you
know netscape kind of
dissolving into aol and not really going
anywhere quickly mozilla
took years to really bring up um the
standard froze and
by 2003 even though they've been sort of
noodling around with advanced versions
javascript two
i'd given the keys to the kingdom to
another mit grad baltimore horwat
very big brain and still google i think
he won the putnam in 86 so he's
yeah very mathematical um he he
he designed this successor language
javascript too but it
it only showed up in mutated form in
microsoft's asp.net server side and it
didn't last there
and it showed up in flash and that's
what became action script three
action script interesting and then and
then flash of course decline and so
how do we arrive at es6 where it's it's
like
there's so many where everyone okay
there's this history of javascript
that people were it was just like cool
when you're like having beers to talk
crap about javascript everyone loves to
hate like people who are married say ah
marriage sucks
is they just want to get let off some
steam even though everyone uses the
language yeah
but es6 ever it's become this like uh
reputable like it fixed major pain
points i think
it added things to the language and
added something that was already es5
strict mode but
made it implicit in class bodies and
module bodies
it was a big jump but it accumulated
some of the es4
designs that we'd done with adobe for
what we hoped would be the fourth
edition of ecmascript
that were supposed to fold in some of
these old javascript two ideas that had
come into action through three
so you look at the family tree and you
see these forks and the main ones
are the the ones that go into adobe
flash acquired from macromedia and the
one that went into the server side of
microsoft's
stack which kind of died and then trying
to bring them back into the standard and
not quite succeeding es4 was was
mothballed
but all the good parts that everyone
liked made it into es6
and so that that was a success and i i
said earlier i had the wrong year i
think it's 2015 so it's off by four
yes yeah it was done finalized in 2015.
it took a little longer than we hoped
but
um because es5 was 2009 and that was a
smaller increment from
es3 we skipped four again we mothballed
it and
we had a split in the committee where
some people said you know es4 is too big
we're going to work on incremental
improvements
no new syntax in particular they they
promised not quite
true but uh they they added a bunch of
interesting apis allen where sprock my
co-author of the hobble paper and he was
at microsoft at the time i ended up
hiring
mozilla he wanted to get to mozilla and
keep doing
the sort of editoring editor job of the
javascript standard
the ecmascript um and when we got
es6 done it was it was a little late
2015
and we switched to year numbers so
people still call it es6 i call it es6
but if you remember you know off by nine
plus two thousand
you